[Music]
I never get tired of the reaction of
people who say Oh 1543 it's amazing that
this book was published in 1543 and that
I can actually touch paper from the 16th
century and touch illustrations that
were created by someone who lived in the
16th century I'm Ann Garner i'm curator
of rare books and manuscripts here at
the New York Academy of Medicine in New
York City today we're looking at Andreas
Vesalius is de human e corporis fabrica
arguably the most important book
published in the 16th century this copy
of the 1543 Vesalius has all of the
marks of where of a 16th century book
this is a book made during the
hand-press period so each copy is unique
right away we notice that Vesalius is
looking at the reader and actually
handling the body the cadaver itself he
is making a deliberate point that in
order to know the body you have to
actually touch and look at and
investigate the body directly these
bodies are extremely accurate in a way
that has never happened before because
he's actually doing dissections himself
one of the things that Vesalius likes to
do is he shows you the body in different
stages of flaying or dissection he's
making a direct reference to the way
that bodies were acquired Italy had
strict rules about the kinds of bodies
that you could use for dissection these
were mostly Church laws
the sailors got most of his bodies from
executed criminals so here you have that
Illustrated literally
[Music]
so it is possible to make an appointment
and come see this book and actually
handle it and look at the woodcut images
up close and read what Vesalius said
about the body
[Music]